when Aegon and his dragons burned her on
the blacken all his sons at Harrenhal
the days when men feared the sight of
our long ships were over Aegon would not
permit Marauders and red is in his seven
kingdoms with Haran died our Empire and
the old way that forged it but what his
dead may never die six years after
Robert Baratheon won his crown my father
Baylon Greyjoy he sought to restore our
ancient rites he declared the Iron
Islands independent and himself its King
and sent the iron fleet in a daring raid
on Lannisport where they burned the
Lannister ships at anchor making us
unchallenged in the sunset sea this was
the seed of our undoing my eldest
brother Roderick led a frontal assault
on sea guard a town built to protect the
mainland rebels after ferocious fighting
beneath the city walls he was slain by
Lord Jason molester and his men defeated
by this time Stannis Baratheon had
brought Roberts fleet around Westeros
and somehow managed to trap the iron
fleet at fair on smashing it Roberts
victory was now all but assured it we
made him bleed for each island Stannis
Baratheon captured great wig the largest
of the Iron Islands and Ser Barristan
Selmy himself subdued old Whig Robert
and Lord Eddard Stark led the main
assault against the island of pike they
razed the town of Lords pot to the
ground before Robert turned his full
fury on our family's stronghold when
they breached the walls the first
through was Thoris of Mia with his
ridiculous flaming sword followed by
every minor Lord of Westeros hungry for
glory
my older brother Marin was killed when
the siege engines brought down a tower
on his head I was now my father's only
living son and heir to the Iron Islands
when my father saw his cause was lost he
wisely conceded defeat to Robert who
otherwise would have pulled down our
castle stone by storm with us in it as
my father said to me then no man has
ever died from bending his knee he who
nails may rise again blade in hand
he who will not kneel stays dead stiff
legs and all as it stuns Robert allowed
my father to keep his lands and title as
lord of the Iron Islands king of salt
and rock son of the Seawind Lord Reaper
of Pike for a price his last son and
heir shipped off to Winterfell as an
honored guest
I would eat at the Starks table and play
with the stark children and if my father
rebelled again Lord Eddard Stark would
take his sword and cut off my head it
would be his duty